how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder and we have absolutely incredible
news today some of you may have caught
my video a couple of hours ago saying
that we could possibly get the Zack
Snyder cut of the Justice League on HBO
Max and it is now official Zack Snyder's
Justice League cut is coming to HBO max
and 2021 next year this is something
that has been demanded by the people for
over two and a half years now
just this morning Zack Snyder and his
wife did a screening of a Man of Steel
they did a watch party for it and Henry
Cavill even joined himself and at the
very end they announced that the Snyder
cut is coming to HBO max in 2021 and
everybody absolutely freaked out now
right now it's a little bit unclear of
what this could be it could be a
four-hour director's cut of the Justice
League that Zack Snyder originally shot
before Joss Whedon came in or it could
be split into six different chapters all
screening on HBO max from what we've
heard it hasn't exactly been decided yet
but the Snyder's are now in the midst of
reassembling much of their original post
production crew to score cut add new and
finish old visual effects and maybe even
bring back some of the actors to add
some additional dialogue here's what
Zack Snyder had to say about the Snyder
cut coming to HBO max it will be an
entirely new thing and especially
talking to those who have seen the
released movie a new experience apart
from that movie he continued to say you
probably saw one fourth of what I did so
the version of what we are going to get
is going to be completely different than
the original Justice League that we saw
in theaters according to Zack Snyder
about 3/4 of it are going to be
completely new and evidently is going to
be nothing like the old film so this is
absolutely incredible news something
that we've been waiting for for over two
and a half years Warner Brothers has
finally listened to the fans and are
giving us what we want we are officially
getting the Snyder cut of the Justice
League in 2021 let me know how excited
you are about this in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the Snyder cut as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof